we play an ugly game
[Music]
you have the determination to win it
[Applause]
[Music]
history does not remember blood
it remembers names
matt i'm putting you on the spot in 10
seconds how many dragons from this
series can you name karaxi's syrax
tyraxis
uh
valerian but he's dead
um
fagar
yeah
that's more than me
that was really good i can't even name
me children so yeah
i had bets out there they said three and
you got six that's
not bad is it i might have added one on
so i'm gonna ask another really um
fluffy question to get things started
right love it the two of you
could have a hair off you both have
great hair in this now i notice you have
more of a blunt cut you have more of a
bob it's more neat yours is wilder you
have a man pony happening i'm wondering
if this reflects your characters in any
way and who do you think has the better
wig
i've got a beautiful gorgeous wig
my wig was made this is more expensive i
had the most expensive wig on the show
yeah you know because he's the kid
so i've got more styles haven't i i
think well i've got some beautiful
styles
let's not go into that
it's just reacting because anyway i
don't want to give it away i don't know
who just won me no way i've got it i've
got my i was the only one with the same
hair palette as daenerys
it was taken from her colours and it's
all about how it matches your skin tone
it's quite a considered thing and all
joking aside your your hair
because some sort of
like
like tones of it they look green against
your skin and all that kind of stuff so
it's it's not just like they love the
big blonde wig you're talking to an la
girl that highlights her hair every
month i was gonna say that's not the way
it is
i wanted to ask you about writing
the mechanical bulls so to speak oh yeah
which is riding a dragon yeah
if we were to have like a hidden camera
on you yeah
and show the behind the scenes of what
that actually looked like can you break
it down for us i heard there's like leaf
blowers like blowing wind yeah i mean
not leafy hooves great yeah yeah they've
got some hemorrhoids going out here
they've got great big wind machines like
this
rain the lot and you're up on a plinth
which is about 20 foot in the air then
they strap you in and then you can't get
down and just up there all day
and then they sort of move you around on
a on like a remote control mechanical
ball did your skills get better over the
season
no not really i was born to do it oh
yeah well i like that cockiness yeah who
really deserves the throne beginning of
season one who do we really think
deserves the throne
me yeah well the air i'm sorry the heir
to the crown
why that was a real beetlejuice moment
me i do i do deserve it by right no he's
he's he has a right he has a right to it
yeah you knicked it off me yeah he did
there's no way there's no way in the
seven hells that i'm gonna name him air
he's too irresponsible you don't know
how i'd react to that
every job he's had he's ballsed off he's
made an absolute mess off there's no way
the question is has he done it on
purpose whereas he just pulls it off no
i didn't do it to hurt you or anything
like that i think that i
why my duty is king i even say i
actually don't think that damon wants to
be king no i don't you know the councils
say you know they think that he's got
designs on it and i'm like he doesn't
want to be king he wouldn't he could not
sit in that he wouldn't say that he
he's afraid of commitment yeah that's
what it is something like that i think
so wow he'd be out on the mary
george has sort of said there's nobody
really good or evil no
like game of thrones there's good and
evil but who do you think is the most
evil and the most good in season one who
do you truly think and a lot of people
have been naming you who's the most cool
well i am yeah
and who have they been naming as the
most evil
otto
oh yeah yeah i'd go with otto do you
agree yeah
because he's the most machiavellian he's
the most serpent he is yeah he's the
puppet master yeah which is why damon
and he says look i see him for what he
is he's a puppet master
he's got you like this yeah george said
real quick that the biggest conflict on
this show is not between people but
within somebody's own heart what do you
think each of your characters biggest
conflict in their heart is i'm ending
things on a very deep note
yeah my biggest conflict
i should never have been named king
god is a tough one why
because really in my heart i wasn't
built to do it
i don't know it's a tough one his
biggest conflict is himself to be honest
and uh and his brother something's with
his brother probably
don't know what because he should never
have been king
his brother exactly exactly
i've inherited your conflict yeah yeah
bastard if rhaenyra comes into power she
can cut off any challenge to her
succession
[Music]
i am to inherit the iron throne
she will block my way
so first of all i heard that when you
two met for the first time that you
instantly were like in love
like was that so was that sort of you're
nodding your head olivia like yes sort
of how was that first meeting uh between
the two people lovely and a relief as
well
yeah
we're just like oh we've yeah home yeah
we've got this yeah we've got each other
yeah really i mean we're [ __ ] lucky
actually because it's you know it's that
rare thing where you meet someone and
there's like an immediate understanding
of familiarity and
that's quite unusual and yeah it is
deeply grateful for it and a lot of the
time on these jobs you're thrown
together and you know you're expected to
have this intense
chemistry and that's something that as
actors all the time we have to work on
yeah and so it's such a treat when it's
just like that okay yeah see you yeah
yeah all good love you all right chill
yeah however would you think ryan was
nervous when he saw how well you got on
because later on they're sort of divided
i hope he was nervous yeah
well but i mean crucially this story is
like that connection and that chemistry
is is sort of fundamental to anything
that happens later and ultimately you
have two people who desperately want
that reunification
won't ask for it but so that that we
like each other it's really handy yeah
that love has to be cemented already to
then
hate each other that's where the pain is
yeah yeah without the love the pain
doesn't work so
emma for you i want you to juxtapose for
me because i heard about your audition
that your phone was propped up on a chip
bag and then you sort of had to
makeshift some hair extensions yeah so
juxtapose that from the first time you
stepped on the set full wig
full like 2000 crew and cast how big a
difference were those two worlds
um
i mean
like i don't even really have language
to describe that added to which we come
into this on the back of a pandemic
where i haven't seen anyone two years uh
i mean
like different worlds and certainly
initially i felt like i'd wanna i felt
like i'd won a competition
and that someone would no no but like
it's very weird to be plucked out your
living room right yes it's also like you
know so little during a pandemic
yeah so
so again this thing's very surreal about
going from yeah like
doing tapes in your bedroom to
arriving on set with 2000 people you
know whatever it is 600 people
um
and then of course
in like no time it becomes wonderfully
familiar and that's you know very nice
that's the joy of it yeah yeah yeah yeah
boring yeah on board
now
so i i know that you hadn't watched game
of thrones before you were cast so then
how did you infuse it did you binge like
when you got the role did you just like
go hard and what were your thoughts so
i'm so glad i hadn't watched game of
thrones before i auditioned because i
think if i
had the feelings towards game of thrones
i have now i wouldn't have gotten the
role because i love it so much and i
think it's so incredible and our
director showrunner miguel sapochnick he
who directed episodes like hard home and
battle of the bastards and he's just
incredible he's the one that has like
shaped
this um
the house of the dragon so if it you
know that was one of our biggest
um
that was one of our biggest turns up
turn-ons
that was one of the things that made us
want to do the job
you know from from the get-go
um
what was the question i'm so sorry no no
you answered it did i oh good good but i
yeah
i can i get turned on watching the show
and i don't know if that's good or bad
but i mean it's a sexy show it's a sexy
it's a sexual it's just a reality yeah
um it's visceral it's in your face so
yeah yeah but no i loved it i mean my
mum binged it together and she's on my
same like now tv account which is what
um jones is on in the uk
and she would be like four or five ahead
of me and so i'd just click on it and be
like what's going on and then something
would happen i'd be like oh no and then
i'm wondering for the two of you because
you have very your characters have very
different relationships with their
father and i think maybe it changes it's
sort of part of maybe the reason why
they end up conflicted with each other
can you talk about how you think those
relationships differ
yeah i mean so for renera
like she adores her dad
and he sort of and he adores her and
simultaneously they share a stubbornness
that means they just can't communicate
i think there is like a really genuine
love there and i i don't think
you talk often about otto making a pawn
of allison i think that's true with
viserys no and yeah
somehow he completely isolates her by
not being able to to communicate and she
wants
his sort of adoration
more than anyone and can't ask for it so
they're at an impasse whereas you kind
of you you do talk
yeah i feel like for me like you've been
granted maybe too much freedom yeah
where you'd love some boundaries yeah
and whereas my relationship with my dad
it's in it's been imposed upon
me that i will live a life of servitude
you know deeply restricted yeah
yeah
your characters have been compared to
cersei and arya do you think it's a fair
comparison because i feel like with your
character she was sort of portrayed as a
pure villain from the narrative in the
book but maybe that we'll see a
different side but do you think those
are fair comparisons
yeah i mean in terms of like archetypes
for sure but they do feel very different
as well and the beauty of game of
thrones is that one minute you love
these characters and the next you
absolutely despise them and i don't
think that's that different for us no
and like if anything
what i would hope is that house of the
dragon has really
really worked to make sure that like as
in life you don't have like goodies and
baddies
everyone's a mix and
kind of that's what makes life so
threatening i think
do you think the realm will ever accept
me as that queen
the lords of the realm bent the knee
a woman would not inherit the iron
throne
because that is the order of things
so first of all congratulations on this
series ryan i want to know if you felt a
little bit like you sat on the iron
throne yourself when george r martin
named you king of this empire
that's that's a really good metaphor i
think it i think it felt very much like
that and then uh i was
i was wondering if
that meant that uh sitting there meant
that um everybody was then going to try
to kill me
if that's an interesting i'm not going
to even say anything to that other than
the fact that what was that cuz i know
you had a lunch with george rr martin
where you sat down and it was the next
day that your agent got that call saying
you know george has a job for you
what did you say to him in that lunch
what happened behind the scenes that you
had such a kinship with him it was well
we had we developed a relationship over
a few years just as just as me as a fan
i got to know him and we became we
became friendly and it was just it was
just nice i mean he was hugely
influential on me as a writer and i was
just a big fan of his so i never
expected anything out of the
relationship at all and i honestly
thought i was just going out for a beer
with him
and he uh he had he'd come in with an
agenda and that was to uh wow to try to
get me to to write this pilot which of
course i i left at the chance and it
really i mean it came together in such
things in this town did not fall out of
the sky like that ever especially good
jobs uh so it was just it was i'm still
stunned by how how it all happened but
uh it felt uh you know it felt like a
bit of um
like daenerys seeing the uh you know
seeing the red comet and in the sky it
was prophecy
things to come miguel they had to drag
you back kicking and screaming from what
i heard after 11 weeks of night shoots
on game of thrones you're an emmy winner
though for you know for your work on
that show one thing that i think fans
are really excited about is 17 dragons i
know we don't even see them all in
season one but sort of can tell me sort
of what went into how do you decide what
dragons are gonna have what
personalities how much fun is that and
they look from what i've seen in episode
one spectacular thank you the the the
dragon process was really i think we
spent over a year designing 13 of the
dragons um and
uh
and it was really interesting we learned
a lot about dragons we had to figure out
things like
um
why dragons die for example you know
what kills a dragon because it seems to
be that
uh that we there was certain mythology
that hadn't been kind of filled out
uh by george so it's quite kind of quite
fun to kind of look for the pieces and
try and figure out how do we how do we
tell a story so that we retrofit our
designs into this uh mythology about
dragons
um
and then
there was the reality of like you know
you can design a dragon all you want and
then you give it to these guys called
the riggers and the riggers basically
take your dragon design they break it
down build a skeleton put the muscles on
it and then try and figure out why it
doesn't fly
um and so there's a lot of you know
caraxies which is uh the bloodworm which
is damon's dragon is a dragon that's
super long he's basically deformed
dragon we call him the elephant man and
um uh and the the funny thing about
karaxis is karaxis really shouldn't fly
because his body's too long for aero any
aerodynamics to work properly and so it
was going back and say oh we've got to
put little kind of wings in his behind
legs for this to actually work
that kind of stuff is pretty fun to do
um
but they're not real you know that right
what are you talking about
oh sorry sorry i won't know i'm going to
export it for you i think i might cry
how could you do this to me um ryan i i
can't even imagine i know you're a prop
collector you even have a podcast about
movie paraphernalia so i'm wondering for
you working on
the iron throne some of the incredible
daggers and this is also the height of
the targaryen dynasty you talk about
from the scope of it to the big things
to like those little details
kind of the undertaking
of this project and how do you make sure
it fits in with what we're going to see
200 years later when we see familiar
sets
yeah i mean i think that that's that's
the great fun of doing doing something
like this where the entire world is
bespoke or custom you know everything
has to be built and constructed and it's
all done with a purpose and a design
behind it and you get all of these
wonderful artisans from all corners who
are their entire focus
is creating this this little piece of
parchment or this dragon's egg or how do
we how dragon's eggs need to be kept
warm how do we keep them warm there
should be a carrier there should be some
kind of kiln to carry it around in and
you get all of this creativity that
comes to you from from the outside just
based on people wanting to make the
world feel like a real place that's
lived in and you get to see all these
you know jim clay our production
designer said something really
interesting to me when we were right at
the outset he said
the the film business in general just
employs all of these these crafts that
would otherwise be extinct you know
clay sculptors and plasterers and yes
you could you could do that as an art
form on the side or have a little etsy
shop but in terms of it being a reliable
career and a and a trade to to to learn
and study and and and grow in and have
some kind of
career path for you it's really the a
lot of those
handmade old things that we used to do
before machines took over everything are
employed by the film industry and you
and you get artists that that pursue
that um so just that's one of the joys
for me is because i can't do i have one
life skill
and if anybody ever if ai takes over
writing i'm really screwed because i
can't do anything else miguel is very
talent he can draw he's good at music
i've i can do one thing
so um so just for me just getting to
watch all of those those people do their
job is one of the greatest joys of my
job now wrap and be but real quick uh if
i'm gonna be a prophet for a second i
think you guys have said you already
know how this is going to end
approximately how many seasons the
baratheons and the starks are teased and
in you know one of the teasers and then
we expect kills from game of thrones is
that mapped out in your brains or is a
lot of it still in flux until i know the
books have been written but in terms of
how it's all going to play out
we have a plan
there's it's only one season long sorry
i gotta tell you now it's just like it's
over after one season we're gonna have
like two episodes next season but
they'll be extremely long about five
hours each and that's gonna be it
no we we do we do we do have a plan i
mean the beautiful thing is that
the dynasty is
has you know 100 years left in it even
after even after the dance of the dragon
so
there's um uh there's plenty of places
to go kind of before and after but this
story has has a defined length to it
simply because of how bloody it is
um and we have we kind of have that in
our head but i think i think the hope is
that there will be an appetite for more
targaryen tales because i think it's
interesting to to to go backwards and
forwards in time and tell tales from you
know before before
before the conquest and then possibly a
time when they were in power but with no
dragons i think there's a lot of
interesting uh themes and landscapes to
explore within that uh 300-year dynasty
but who else would have a claim
the firstborn child renera
no queen has ever sat the iron front
the king has an heir damon targaryen
i will not be made to choose between my
brother and my daughter okay first i
have to ask you yes you have a joust and
then you have a flirt yeah who flirts
after they gel
kristen cole
chris christmas christmas christmas
christmas christmas christmas came early
christmas came early yeah uh yeah i
don't know i don't know how he did that
yeah it was weird thinking about it i
don't know that i would have the energy
to kind of go i think that it's a move
because it's like i just beat your
uncles yeah
yeah yeah and the he's the best and he's
the bus i mean
yeah and it was just so easy
the fight yeah oh yeah that's what i'm
saying oh she's like so easy i have to
have energy tonight yeah yeah yeah i
guess so yeah it wasn't easy for me
at all no i was exhausted were you yeah
uh
yeah tell me about it it was well it's
it you're throwing a a ball with his
sticks on it on a chain it's kind of
made of plastic but it's still kind of
it's got weight to it it's got weight to
it so that it does the thing and also it
rebounds off the shield and i and you
don't want to go into too much detail
but there are areas uh
in which you don't want uh a ball with
spikes to rebound and hit so a lot of it
was kind of like you're really good
with your hips
uh uh so i did a lot of hip a little hip
work a lot of action
yeah riding dragons more difficult are
you like arguing oh no actually
oh it is okay mate you just kind of like
propped up on this like basically like
uh like saddle and they just kind of
move you around that's it i don't know
what to do i didn't have to train like
fab had to train and everything no
actually quite simple but you have to do
high valerian i just have to do a hive
which is okay so that balances it out
you asked matt
i asked matt like if there was like a
hidden camera on each of you riding a
dragon like who like what would it look
like would you look ridiculous because
there's a leap i mean
it's quite easy for me to look
ridiculous so yeah i look ridiculous
what did matt say
he basically said i said did you get
better over the season he says no i was
born to do it oh that is such an ms
answer so smack
so i've been asking everybody today like
we do there's really no good or evil in
this show
who in your opinion though and your
personal opinion is the most evil and
the most good in season one
i i think rainier is the most good
oh and i think the most evil
oh
maybe yeah
yeah matt matt
matt smith actually yeah not matt smith
not the character
no no no no no no no no no no no sorry
damon tucker
is a lovely man uh uh dave and targaryen
yeah and uh
david's gay david
oh
about insomnia me and him me and david i
have sex almost every single day for the
last six months
does the cast have group checks we have
some group tests
we can't read anything about there are a
few group chats one started that was a
disaster it started at the beginning and
it lasted maybe three days
and then there's another one that i'm on
you're just very popular that's not true
um
yes
yes we have i can't change just us
complaining it's us complaining
someone going like do you know what the
crafties have got on does anyone know
does anyone know if there are burritos
at crust what is this smoothie yeah yeah
what is yeah yeah yeah why does my rice
look like that
were there burritos back then um will a
burrito make its way onto set
in episode one sort of how epic was that
from i mean it was pretty it was pretty
epic i remember reading it and being
like
here's the line
um and yeah i mean she doesn't want to
say it in the scene that she that she
has to say which is kind of what is so
heartbreaking about it but no i feel
very like it was very surreal to say
such an iconic line in such an iconic
context yeah can you tease i mean this i
sort of know because of the books i know
a little bit about this relationship
that sort of starts to unfold can you
tease a little bit about we can't we
can't
we can show you we can show you okay
hi i'm kristen co rene nice to meet you
nice to meet you
that's it that's it that's
that's what it is that's kind of that's
what we have i think it's good yeah
succession will be challenged
knives will come out
you are the king
your first duty is to pick a new wife
so let's talk about this power couple on
the show are you two the biggest power
couple yes yes why
wow
so
um we're badass we're the richest
um
um
[Music]
and she's incredibly smart
incredibly politically astute
and when he's
you know got his sense around him he
listens to her i think the thing about
us as well is that we're probably the
two people in the court well and i i
suppose damon as well because he's a
he's a sort of
live wire and nobody quite um
dynamite but
nobody wants to mess with us
oh i love that yeah i want it
because we also control the navy because
we are seafarers and so the realms navy
is basically our navy so yeah and we
don't really care how people think about
us interesting i find it interesting
because you were of course i don't want
to say but the queen that never was and
then you're also the wealthiest you've
traveled the most you're the most
worldly so how do the two of you
reconcile not being at the top
i don't know that they
don't think they have reconciled no i
don't think he certainly hasn't
and i don't think she has either i think
she's way better at covering it because
she's such a good politician she's
superb at appearing that everything's
okay
he's just like
you know um so i don't know that they i
love that yeah me too i actually quite
like that about him that he's so
uh so macho macho and so and so
taking on the the the insult to his wife
he's great
yeah i feel very protected by you yes so
you should yeah so i'm not sure that
they have reconciled yes no no
reconciliation bubbling underneath yeah
and i think an awful lot of the
motivation for the the season is him
trying to find ways to get them
yeah either to the top or better access
to the top and i think and the journey
that they both go on is quite
interesting it's like they end up
slightly in the opposite places
i want to talk about this delicious line
that you get to say that is in the
trailer so i'm not spoiling anything but
men would sooner put the realm to the
torch than see a woman ascend the iron
throne how delicious was it to say it
such great dialogue but it's also
foreshadowing a lot i mean i was hooked
into the show when i first met ryan and
miguel and miguel said um
uh you know the the whole sort of arc of
this story of this particular story
is based around this line which is
that men would sooner put them around to
the torches and see a woman and send the
iron throne and it's like that that is
where we start and that is where the
journey the whole of this story is about
that fact and the unraveling of this
ancient
patriarchal
really pretty corrupt and dysfunctional
system
which
weirdly is not that
similar
to where we are today
george said in one of the panels that he
did that there is no character that's
really good or evil as opposed to game
of thrones that this one there's a lot
of gray area with these characters but
in your personal opinion who's the most
evil and the most good in season one
oh wow god
i think
answering who's the most good might be a
easier
question than it was bad i think you
know i think he's the most sort of good
good and inverted commas but it would be
i would say the series oh of course yeah
i was actually going to say raniera but
you're right viserys i would say though
rainier is very much very high so she's
very lazy
okay so for saris yeah in terms of he's
good he's like a good guy a good guy
he's just an innocent who found himself
in the wrong situation yeah it feels yes
it feels like
oh do you know he's an innocent high
tower
rhys he's the most evil most evil easel
on floating
yeah yeah he's the one yeah yeah get him
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed my hair up on the iron
throne
your credits in the amount of projects
that you've done between the witcher
between outlander the voice of loki
over 100 credits as an actor i think
around 135 so where does this show fit
in the pantheon
of your career
yeah no well um this oh this is a
fantastic show yeah i mean i've i was a
huge fan of the original um
i knew ryan condell from two previous
shows that we've worked on together
and uh we were both very keen to work
together again and we used to have lunch
and actually talk about this
when it was
not guaranteed at all not greenlit
um you know there were a number of shows
competing for the same spot
and uh and we both had this wonderful
kind of ambition to be able to see this
come to fruition and it is one it's
fabulous uh especially for ryan
but for me as well to actually be a part
of something that i've long wanted to be
a part of okay so because you were sort
of there at its inception what about
ryan's vision and his ability to lead do
you think made george rr martin sort of
name him him the successor to the game
of thrones kingdom because he's kind of
like the appointed king by george r
martin i know i mean i don't know if
ryan's told you this uh i'd hate to be
sort of speaking out of turn but um when
we were doing a a pilot in new mexico we
were in santa fe and of course george
lives around there
and uh ryan
and i love this about ryan
massive fan and he basically um
pursued george and said you know we
regret to sit down and have lunch and
they just became friends
and uh became very
very sort of involved with each other
and creatively and uh and and here we
have the result and i just think that's
the most wonderful story that was nine
years ago
that that happened and so from that
moment to this this wonderful full
experience that we're now having um is
is down to that and i think that's a
great story
so your character had served king
jaharis and king viserys did you sort of
delve into the back story and who do you
think is the better leader between the
two of them
well
um
much as i love berseras
i think it's pretty it was probably i
mean the problem is i mean it's very
difficult he he he has a very very
difficult role i mean not paddy but
viserys and patty
um
the way he even became
king
already placed him on a path of conflict
really
and
and that's what's so wonderful about the
world that george created and the world
that ryan and miguel are creating with
the show
is that these uh these are kind of these
have echoes in real history these people
that came to power
somewhat reluctantly somewhat by
accident tried to do their best tried to
do the right thing and then there were
these other forces at work
that were trying to undermine them or
trying to what they believed was like do
the right thing and you know so much of
history is littered by people who felt
they were doing the right thing were
really doing the wrong thing
and so yeah this fits really well into
that and we have the bonus of dragons of
course well i'm going to add one more
contest into the equation who do you
think
better natural born leader king viserys
or jamie frazier
the king of men
um
natural book leader goodness me that's a
look you know jamie fraser doesn't have
to deal with dragons so you know come on
give the guy a break viserys is he's got
a lot on his plate i mean jamie's just
got the american war of independence
so it's it's nothing compared with what
berseras has to deal with so i i think
paseras is doing really well and i would
say that because i'm your commander of
the kingsguard and as commander i mean
it seems like this is a show of ambition
as well there's there are people that
don't start out ambition vicious and
then they become ambitious and maybe it
corrupts them and corrupts their heart
where do you fall in the line of this
what is your character because yours
seems sort of the most selfless in a way
from the get-go but i don't know where
it goes because i haven't read the book
i am uh
well i'm a morally upright individual
yes i am
uh which is an unusual step for me in my
career and
he's he's just somebody that um sees
things very simply
and also uh occupies a place in what is
almost like a pseudo-religious order the
king's guard sort of reminiscent of the
knights templar you know that he he
abandons all kind of
worldly delights you know there's no
relationships for harold there's there's
no money there's nothing there's just
the targaryens
no no chair probably no bed
he's just
devoted to them so he's a very um
straight guy
and uh
and
he has his opinions about everybody but
he tries his very best to keep those
opinions to himself just before i let
you go at the start of season one
who do you think is the rightful heir to
the throne
oh i think rene yeah
definitely raniera
definitely i do i believe that she's the
right choice
yes
i
i endorse this message
you